vous me dites quelque chose à cerner que
si l'événement vous allez devoir il est
ou non
vous allez devoir enquêter donc et poser
des questions sophie koch est ce que
vous avez fait le buzz il ya longtemps
plus de dix ans on va dire ce que vous
avez beaucoup changé physiquement
oui un peu vous avez fait le buzz ya
plus de dix ans - gil est voit un grand
gagnant d'un jeu télévisé a pas du tout
m'engueuler pas pas du tout maxime par
exemple n'avait pas été révélée par une
émission de télévision oh non on peut le
dire il a fait certains sur internet
c'était sur internet alors je propose
qu'on regarde un premier indice pour
nous aider un peu premier indice s'il
vous plaît en régie sur internet
à ses ouïes un peu bizarre avec du
scotch du scot sur le visage bernard est
ce que vous avez créé une performance
sur internet
relativement oui un championnat est-ce
que vous avez imiter et frères bogdanoff
sur internet
non gilles encore avez-vous battu un
record en durée
avec une épreuve difficile sur internet
bon alors là vous êtes complètement à la
masse vous le dit deuxième
essai dont les pirates sécurité
renforcée maxime dillies avez vous lancé
un challenge sur le web non non non
baptisé vous fait une action vraiment
héroïque qui a été filmé bon dont jean
mi est ce que vous avez fait des vidéos
ou parliez de sécurité contre les
terroristes qui a fait le buzz qui était
vu des millions de fois parce que vous
aviez beaucoup d'humour ça a été pris au
premier degré site est très drôle bonne
réponse de jean michel mr bravo jean
deysel
c'est donc vous aviez louis ii ids
arrache prononce bien oui deux fillettes
avec nous habiller louis de izarra
xavier lui devait le rencontrer moi
j'étais où toutes ces vidéos ont fait
pisser dessus ah oui sur la a lieu s'il
révèle comment draguer l'étranger etc
alors z il a fait le buzz c'était en
2016 avec une vidéo qui a été vue près
de 500 mille fois quand même dans cette
vidéo il donne des conseils pour
neutraliser un terroriste un conseil et
oui un peu étonnant à regarder c'est
génial
règles essentielles
extrêmement important ne t'en panique
est resté zen dont vous respirez
profondément
au moment où lève son arme vers vous
vous déviez le canon vous lui mettez les
deux doigts dans le nez
par effet kléber à la tête vous lui
donnez un coup derrière vous terminez
par une percute il se retrouve pas et se
retrouve par terre et là vous avez sur
vous un rouleau de stock vous le la
tâche et vous appelez la police ils vous
livrer directement kate mais entendu ici
vous avez plusieurs terroristes en face
de vous mais avoir une telle opération
autant de choix qu'il ya deux
terroristes face à vous
voilà la méthode ont neutralisé les
terroristes et un quad cette vidéo
comment est ce que vous avez eu l'idée
de la faire
par hasard je pensais pas du tout cas
les faire le buzz je m'amusais avec à
poney de ses six une vidéo qui me
plaisait dans le sens où je critiquais
finalement les gens qui disent les
théoriciens qui veulent neutraliser des
terroristes ou combattre dans la rue dd
des voyous il autour des techniques
extraordinaires mais lorsqu'ils sont
face à la réalité bobin ce fondement gs
qu'est ce qu'ils ont mais c'est que les
gens assez longtemps à pouvoir vous
c'était de l'humour il ya plein de gens
que c'est spécial c'est d'être très haut
degré ce qu'eux-mêmes et vidéo aurait
été ya trois niveaux de lecture il ya le
premier niveau qui est très basique tout
le monde solutions dont me prends
vraiment pour un cinglé deuxième niveau
où l'ajustement je transmet un message
et enfin un troisième niveau qui est qui
porte sur la spiritualité et qui souvent
est caché il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens
qui le voient c'est évident les hommes
sont comme ça elles sont structurées
femme très selon ces trois niveaux est
donc non mais ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
c'est une affaire de julien il ya des
gens qui l'ont pris au premier degré
dont
cyril hanouna et vous la vidéo est passé
dans tp mais
elle était passée mais franchement
xavier quand on voit la vidéo c'est
difficile de croire que oui même si
c'est tout à fait macgibbon c'était sa
personne comme ça a été pris au premier
degré nous vous a causé de problème on
vous a pas justement
c'est qu'il ya le bon cyril ils sont
rendus compte a pris des baous est en
fait une blague il suffit d' approfondir
un peu de voir deux ou trois de mes
vidéos ça on a compris
sauf que il y a eu le chef de service de
mon épouse ah et oui et là ça a été très
très loin j'ai donc c'est une histoire
d'âme parce que drôle en fait c'est que
lui il l'a prise au premier degré et mon
épouse travaille au service de la zone
euro chez eux au conseil départemental
de la haute vienne et 87 et il a dit
mais celui-là où là il a regardé la
vidéo il a vu au premier degré il bosse
est un fou aussitôt en urgence il a
téléphoné encore à sa hiérarchie bon il
dit chez les deux buts à rien vous parce
qu'on leur a confié une petite fan mais
la kia qui a cinq ans elle avait un
temps à l'époque quand on quand on avait
eu et il faut la lui retirer de très
très rapidement parce que c'est vraiment
fou et d'autre part son épouse ne s'est
pas rendu compte que c'était un fou donc
elle aussi est folle donc il faut la
retirer alors on a eu des soutiens de de
la maîtresse de la petite fille qui nous
était confié le soutien du maire il ya
le monde
mon médecin traitant qui m'a fait un
certificat médical pour dire que je
dépends fougue de ma santé mentale était
tout à fait normal et là quand il a vu
sa et di resta c'est pas possible ils
sont tous fous dans le village de
châteauneuf la forêt en haute vienne
c'est tous dévoués
xavier il paraît que votre femme a
failli perdre son travail ou a perdu son
travail à cause de la vie là bas donc
qu'ils ont retiré la petite et parce que
vous êtes vous habitiez oui mais ils ont
retiré la petite elle est privée bourrée
elle est heureuse alors mon épouse
heureuse ou s'y épanouir dans son
travail parce que son bonheur c'est de
s'occuper des enfants voilà de rendre
les enfants heureux on adore les enfants
donc ça va loin et oui alors donc ce qui
s'est passé c'est que elle a été
licenciée oh là là mais ça a été ça a
été plus loin donc de la jeudi à temps
il faut faire quelque chose lorsqu'il
faut quand même neutraliser la connerie
différents domaines et notamment je me
suis mis coach anti conneries voilà il
donc là j'ai écrit un livre sur
comment vous pouvez vous occupez de
jean-michel même si vous êtes tout
chantier conneries bon we are well
plaisir
[Applaudissements]